- Welcome, everyone, to
CIFAR's series of virtual talks
on the theme Science as the Exit Strategy.
These talks are intended
to share how research
from across the academy,
from computer science,
population and public health
to economics and
anthropology form the basis
for evidence-informed decision making
as governments begin
planning how best to reopen
shuttered societies and economies
in the wake of COVID-19.
If you're not familiar with us,
CIFAR is a Canadian-based
global charitable organization
that convenes extraordinary minds
to address some of science
and humanity's most important
and pressing questions.
Like many other organizations
across the globe,
CIFAR has pivoted quickly
to take action on COVID-19,
launching new projects and initiatives,
some of which we are highlighting
through this webinar series.
My name is Kate Geddie.
I am senior director of research at CIFAR,
and it's my true pleasure
to introduce you today
to Professor Hendrik Poinar.
Hendrik is professor of anthropology
at McMaster University,
where he draws on his training
in molecular evolutionary genetics
and biological anthropology
to address questions about past pandemics.
In particular, he uses chemical
and molecular techniques
within forensic, archeological,
and paleontological remains
to ask questions such as
which pathogens are
responsible for past pandemics?
He's also a fellow in CIFAR's
Humans and the Microbiome program,
and he'll be sharing with us today
how knowledge of past pandemics
can inform our understanding
of the COVID-19 pandemic.
So, Hendrik, to start
off our conversation,
I'd like to ask you about the broad themes
that emerge in art
depicting past epidemics.
So, for example, looking at this painting
by Antoine Jean Gros,
hopefully that'll be coming up, yep,
that centers on Napoleon,
what role does historical art play
in how we view and think about pandemics?
- Oh, so first, thanks for having me.
It's a pleasure and
honor to be part of this
talking point today,
and welcome to everybody who's listening.
Yeah, I mean, this is a great painting.
Art has always been a powerful way
for people to reflect
and comment on pandemics,
socially, politically, and individually.
This, it's a perfect tool,
art, to illustrate both human
and political responses
to pandemics in the past
and, probably not
surprisingly to most of you,
is tremendously relevant today.
There's lots of important points in this.
We could talk about this
painting for hours and hours,
but I'll try to minimize those to a few
of the important points.
So, first, if we put it into context,
this is painted by
Antoine Jean Gros in 1804
and is titled "Napoleon Bonaparte Visiting
"the Plague-Stricken at Jaffa",
and this was part of
Napoleon's Egyptian campaign
to fight the Ottomans as he
moved across Egypt and Syria.
And this takes place basically
after the brutal siege of Jaffa in 1799,
and shortly thereafter,
there was an outbreak of bubonic plague.
And most of you will know, of course,
that plagues and war go hand-in-hand.
And so if we thing about plague
and sort of bubonic plague,
an 18th century plague epidemic,
this is one of the last ones recorded
in the Middle East and Europe.
This is a descendant, this epidemic,
of the famous Black Death
which happened in 1346
and spread across Europe
killing about 50 million people.
But I think importantly
that that number seems out of context
unless you place it into
the overall mortality rate,
which is something between 30 and 40%
of the total population which is...
We think about the
numbers today with COVID,
and they are dramatic nonetheless,
but I think in terms of the
context of the total population,
it was a tremendous wipe,
of course, to the Europeans.
So, here, Napoleon is visiting
his plague-stricken soldiers,
and he sits, I think what's so interesting
is that there's really
two important points
that I wanna illustrate in this painting.
One, of course, is he sits
dead center of this painting,
and of course, we'll talk about, really,
the meaning of that in a second.
The light's hitting him from the top.
And of course, it's drawn at the time
in an Oriental framework,
which was a very important
part of European life.
There's sort of the mystery
of the Orient at that time.
So, I think the most important
narrative that it draws upon
is this idea of use versus them.
This is a typical narrative of epidemics.
We always think about people,
those that are sick and
those that are healthy.
But this case, of course,
there's a double entendre
because those that are sick,
and you can see at the
center of the painting
Napoleon touching a sick soldier,
actually touching a bubo
of the sick soldier.
These soldiers are supposed
to be his French soldiers,
but they look very similar to the soldiers
at the very front of the painting
in the dark sort of shadows,
which are also Arab
soldiers that are dying,
Ottoman soldiers that are
dying from the plague as well.
And I think here you have the balance
of the sick versus the healthy,
but you also have this narrative of
the disease came from
afar, came from away.
And it describes this idea
of what we call European exceptionalism,
that the Europeans could never
themselves harbor disease.
It was always diseases
coming from the East.
And it's probably strange or maybe not
that we still have that narrative
playing out today, right?
COVID is a Chinese disease
or a Chinese virus,
and that's no different
than what we saw here.
In fact, our work, actually,
on the DNA of plague victims
throughout Europe throughout
the second pandemic
show that, actually,
that's not at all true.
Plague actually maintained
itself in local reservoirs
and kept emerging,
so plague was a very European disease
even though the Europeans
like to think of themselves
as being exceptional.
And so in this case, the
disease is coming from the East.
It's coming from people that don't know
how to care for themselves
and take care for themselves
and so on and so forth,
and so I think that's one
of the important narratives,
us versus them.
The second thing that I think is probably
extremely relevant today is that,
remember that this is a propaganda piece.
This was commissioned by Napoleon in 1804
to be a piece that would allow him
to rise as emperor, right?
He wasn't emperor at this point,
but he was hoping that this piece
would sort of help illuminate
several of his important points.
Napoleon sits dead center.
We have the light, basically,
from the heavens highlighting Napoleon,
and he's doing what we know
from the Bible, of course,
Christ did with lepers
or the king during medieval
times would do with sick people,
which is basically laying
the hands upon the sick
in the attempts to heal them.
So, but it's also to illustrate
to the people in France
that Napoleon was tremendously brave,
that he would unglove himself.
I mean, how important are gloves
in the current pandemic,
what we think about,
but he's taking off his glove
and he's actually touching the bubo.
And if we can just zoom
in on that illustration
in the next image,
can see that not only is he touching that,
but look at his officers
and his doctors who are
both behind him, right?
They're horrified, which is
the true representation of,
as the painter knew,
people were scared out of
their minds about plague
because plague had
repeatedly erupted in Europe
for 400 years killing millions
and millions of people.
And so this doctor behind him
is not surprisingly donning a mask.
And of course, that's a narrative theme
that we have repeatedly introduced today
and actually, unfortunately,
back and forth, right?
It should've been wearing
masks from the beginning,
and of course, we got conflicting messages
about how useful those would be.
And so the doctor behind him is saying,
"Hey, Napoleon, you're
nuts, this is crazy."
But of course, as part
of the propaganda piece,
it gives legitimacy,
of course, to the power
and to his domineering role,
that he has this heavenly, God-like power
that he can touch the
sick, hopefully heal them,
and therefore maintain a
level above the common people.
So, this power illustrated
in this illustration
is really a legitimacy to continue ruling.
- Well, that's really
interesting and that,
as you've alluded to
in your response there,
some of our current practices
in response to COVID-19
also are not new.
I mean, you've talked about
the wearing of the mask,
but also maybe if we go to another image
that we have here from the 1918 flu,
we can see that the sick are
often isolated from the healthy
just as we're attempting to quarantine
those sick with the coronavirus.
So, I mean, what do our responses
tell us about the relationship between,
on the one hand, scientific understandings
and social practices such as
stigmatization on the other?
- Yeah, they're two very important points.
Yeah, I mean, this is Camp Funston, Kansas
with the American soldiers
that are sick of influenza,
and of course, the scientific
reason for quarantine,
of course, is to stem or
quell the spread of infection.
And this, of course, comes from,
actually, the earliest
known quarantine examples
come from the city of Ragusa,
which, of course, is modern day Dubrovnik,
and the Venetians closely thereafter
took it as quaranta, quarantine,
40 days of keeping a ship
on these small islands
off the coast of Venice
in the hopes of quelling the disease.
But of course, you think
about that 40 days on a ship,
and yet every time I think about quaranta,
I think about the poor
people on the cruise ships
and thinking how uncomfortable this is.
I mean, so the scientific
reason, of course,
is the hope to keep the disease at bay,
but of course, there's political
and social motivation for doing this.
So, this is the 1918 influenza epidemic,
and no government at the time
wanted to acknowledge its
presence, right, on their soil.
In fact, all Western journalists in Europe
and in North America were banned and fined
and threatened with prison
time if they reported on it.
And there's only one country
that actually reported freely on it,
and of course, that was Spain,
hence the name Spanish Flu.
And so this just illustrates, again,
that the quarantine serves
a political purpose,
which is to make the sick
not visible to the rest of us.
And so quarantine,
actually, we try to frame,
governments will try to frame quarantine
as being an important
part to protect everybody
and to help those that are sick,
but of course, it never is.
It's never for those who need it the most,
which are the sick.
It's always a way to
protect the population
from those that are sick, right?
And so maybe another way to look at that
is the next illustration, which is...
Yeah, this is the TB
patients in a sanatorium.
And of course, many of you probably know
of a sanatorium just in your backyards.
I mean, there's one here in Hamilton
and there's several across
Toronto and upstate New York.
And these were TB patients.
And they were sent to
sanatorium not out of the,
what I like to call the
Thomas Mann sort of romantic,
alpine vision of oh, it's
gonna be beautiful days
looking at these edelweiss
in the Swiss Alps,
but rather, this was a
fear of the general public.
And what did it cause?
It actually caused social death
because you were completely
isolated from your family,
you were isolated from your community,
you were isolated from
any culture that you had,
and you were sent there,
basically, to die.
And so, again, quarantines serve
both political and social interests,
but really, they never end up serving
those who need it the most,
which are usually the sick.
- Wow, that's quite a striking
comment to end on there.
Well, maybe then, I'll
transition to a question
that's in quite a different vein,
which is the CIFAR group
that you're a part of,
the Humans and the Microbiome program,
is interested in how the
microbes that live in
and on us affect our
health and development.
We're often commenting
today on the negative impact
that our overly or hyper
hygienic approaches
are having on our microbial diversity.
What role has hygiene
played in past pandemics?
- Yeah, I mean, that's a
really important question
given the group that I'm a part of
and fortunate to be a part
of, Human and the Microbiome.
I mean, hygiene, if we
look at the next image,
hygiene has a long, much longer history
than most of us appreciate.
The earliest accounts,
and these are actually
written accounts, of course,
they're the seventh century
Greek goddess Hygeia,
who was also later a
Roman goddess as well,
sanitation, cleanliness, and health.
And so this is quite old,
our appreciation of cleanliness
is next to godliness, right?
And for the Romans, as shown
here in the illustration below,
it was all about controlling the water.
Water was personal hygiene,
so think about the Roman
baths, for instance,
but it was also about
removal of fetid water
and sewage and so on and so forth,
so some of the earliest
sewers, of course, were Romans.
They were exposed at some of the time,
but still, it was the idea
was to get rid of waste.
And I find it really interesting
because most of our sense of what we,
when we think about the
Middle Ages and hygiene,
we think of the Monty
Python's Holy Grail, right,
in which the guy dragging a cart
with dead bodies through the town,
and there's nothing but feces everywhere
and it's dark and grim and muddy.
And that's always our
perpetuated image of that,
but we have evidence actually suggesting
it really wasn't like
that in all situations.
Yes, in impoverished parts of
the city, it might have been.
In most cases, it really wasn't.
People took much more care.
So, I'd like say, we've
probably had this disconnect
with our world since the rise of cities,
and hygiene has probably
played a role in that
diminution of that
microbiome over a long time.
But really, today, there's
been an acceleration
in that destruction of
our microbial constituents
in a hyper hygienic or
overly sanitized world,
and that comes mostly because
of our fear of microbes right?
I mean, all I have to do
is throw up some images
of what plague was like
in the Middle Ages,
and you talk about people,
30% of the population dying,
makes good sense that people were
really, really scared
about microbes, right?
Microbes became the sort of,
the evil and feared thing,
certainly when germ theory came about
and we started identifying and
linking particular bacteria
with known infectious diseases.
And so I think because of
this over hyper sanitization
that we go through now with Purell,
I mean think about how important
Purell is currently, right,
we've also, at the same time,
we've sort of diminished
our microbial constituents,
which are our first line of defense
both orally and in the gut
as a way to defend
ourselves against infection.
So, I think it's...
Importantly, as people in the group,
the Human and the Microbe
group have pointed out,
there's a pendulum that
swings back and forth,
and in the times of active
infectious disease and pandemics,
hygiene is exceptionally important,
washing your hands,
making sure that if you come
into contact with somebody
you wash your clothes,
you try to wear a mask,
you try to clean things
that enter your house.
So, that's an exceptionally
important point now,
but the problem is how will we behave
when the pandemic is over, right?
The behaviors during the Black Death,
they continued for a long time thereafter.
People had a hard time
switching back because,
certainly in the case of Black Death,
you had these repeated epidemics,
so you were never really
without infectious disease.
So, will we maintain
this hyper sterilization
that we're going through now
and increase it, actually, more fold
because of this epidemic,
or will we switch back to
sort of a more healthier way,
which is a return to nature
rather than a continued
removal from nature?
As our fearless leader
Brett Findlay would say,
"Let them eat dirt," right?
Return to the Earth so that
we can use those microbes
as a way to stimulate our immune system
in the event that that would
actually better protect us
from the next coming pandemic.
- That's interesting and
another question I have,
and I'm thinking about this also
just looking at the backdrop
that you have there,
the sort of dance macabre behind you,
as you certainly know as
a scholar of pandemics,
that it can often be quite a dark topic.
But I'm wondering if it's
possible to also talk about
how responses to certain epidemics
have shown something
inspiring about humanity?
- Yeah, yeah, I think
it's always important.
I mean, pandemics have a
tendency to bring out the worst
but then, also importantly,
bring out the best.
I mean, I think there's a
balance that comes to the fear
and loss in a sense of community,
and it can strengthen
relationships between people.
It can strengthen community relationships.
It can strengthen your love
for particular individuals.
During the Black Death,
one of the famous engravings
is Death carrying off children
because there was such
a high mortality rate
of infants and children.
And so thereafter, children
became much more important.
Not that they weren't before,
but there was this, much more
of a sense of preciousness
with children after the Black Death
took so many of them away.
And I think today about frontline workers.
I also think about our elders
who we've, again, quarantined
in essence, in a way.
And I think of them in terms
of the sanatorium movement
and how, will elders be more
precious in the years to come
because they're now isolated?
We can't actually have
direct contact with them.
My parents are both
elderly, not yet in homes,
but are being isolated themselves,
and we can't see or speak
and talk to them on a one on
one basis out of complete fear.
And so I think it's
gonna change our behavior
and our perspective on that.
I think, importantly,
I'm reminded every day of
the banging of the pots
at seven o'clock for the
frontline workers in the ER
and all those important things.
I'm thinking about the Italians
singing on their balconies.
And so I think even though
these are dark times
and they certainly, in past epidemics,
have brought exceptionally dark times,
I think there's a tremendous
balance that comes with
some of the beauty that
comes out of individuals
making tremendous signs
of appreciation and love,
and that's what can help us carry us
through these challenging times.
- Wow, well, thank you so much, Hendrik,
for sharing your insights with us.
Perhaps now I'm gonna turn
to some of the questions
that have come in from our audience.
So, one that's come in is
why do so many diseases
leading to pandemics seem
to come from animals?
- Yeah, well, I mean,
most of the diseases,
the infectious diseases,
well, about 60 to 70% of
them are zoonotic in origin.
That is they jump from animal
reservoirs into humans.
In the case of plague, of
course, these were rodents.
Rodents are known to
harbor Yersinia pestis,
and they jumped, unfortunately,
by spillover events
that come from rodent
infections or rodent epidemics
that then spill into humans.
And these are just,
unfortunately, accidental
emergences that happen
when humans come into
close proximity, right?
So, you think about humans
during the medieval ages
and the populations are growing
and all of a sudden you have an expansion
into a more natural land.
Maybe you're farming that land
and so now you come into
contact with these rodents
that then harbor these pathogens,
which are in some cases not infectious
to the rodent themselves.
And so then they spill
accidentally into humans.
And we know that that's the same case,
of course, with COVID.
These are bat origin, most likely,
but it seems like they
can infect a wide host
of other mammalian animals.
So, there's talk of
course of the pangolins,
so there seems to be a really
interesting evolutionary link
between a pangolin and a bat,
and now they're talking
about, of course, ferrets
and other felines and so on and so forth.
So, a large percentage of
these infectious agents
are still out there.
In fact, I mean, I think the
latest estimates are about
2% of the known variome has
actually been sequenced,
so there's a lot of viruses,
RNA viruses out there
that are sitting in hosts.
And, of course, as we continue
and encroach on these landscapes,
we're gonna run into these
spillover events repeatedly.
- Another question that
kinda picks up on that point
that's come in is how,
then, do we convince people
that not all microbes are bad?
- Well, I think the group
that I'm lucky to be a part of
is one way to do that.
I mean, we have to educate the young.
And I see it happening all the time.
We talk about the important
bacteria in yogurt,
the important bacteria in cheese and milk
and how eating healthy vegetables can add
important fiber to your gut
and your gut contains all these microbes,
and so I think we need to,
we've really talked
about individual bacteria
over the course of history
that have had massive
effects on mortality rates,
but we need to talk in the same way
about all these great bacteria,
the lactobacillus, for example,
that are important bacteria from milk,
that are dairy-based products
that play a tremendous role
in providing important neurotransmitters
and communicate back and
forth with our brains
and can modulate depression and anxiety
and in some cases even obesity.
So, there's a tremendous,
I think the more we sort
of open up this fantastic
microbial box that is our system,
our holobiont as it's placed,
that we are not just human cells.
We're sort of more bacterial and viral
and fungal cells than we are human,
which is an interesting
way to think about it.
And as that becomes increasingly
more and better known,
I think people will really appreciate
there's a fine balance between those
that are really problematic,
which it's really a handful.
It's a very small number
of infectious agents so far
that have really caused
the kind of epidemics
that I sort of study in the past.
The bulk of them do very little
to us if anything at all,
and a huge host of them that we live with
are synthons, helpful, (mumbles)
that help us digest foods
and fight infection
and so on and so forth.
- That's terrific there.
I'm sort of almost distracted
by all these questions.
I think this conversation could
go on for quite a long time.
I'm having to choose amongst
terrific questions here,
but maybe I'll ask one of the
ones that just just came in.
But it's, the question
is that it seems that
with most plagues there
are great inequalities
in how they affect different groups
and populations in society.
Can you think of examples where societies
have handled these
diseases more equitably?
- Oh, that's a very good question.
Epidemics and pandemics
are an immediate window
onto the state of affairs
of any particular country,
county, nation, however
you wanna divide it,
and they show, they immediately
bring to the surface
the inequity that exists within societies.
So, your question was is there,
can I think of a case where
they dealt more equitably?
That's a really, really good question.
Off the top of my head, unfortunately, no.
I mean, the one thing epidemics do
is they immediately highlight
government failures, right?
And so in any case where you have
dramatic inequality of
wealth, for example,
pandemics always, always effect
those of lower socioeconomic income
much harder than they do the other ones,
those that aren't in those situations,
because they don't have access
to proper food and nutrition
and so their immunocompromised.
They don't have access to clean water.
We know that's a big problem today
across even our country, right?
The indigenous populations in the north,
they don't have access to
proper healthcare and medicines,
so this is a question I'll
take with me after this
to really think hard about
because it certainly doesn't
come to mind immediately.
Most of the cases that I
can think about of the past
always shows dramatic inequity
across populations unfortunately, sadly.
And it's still true today
in the current epidemic,
again highlighting all these
social issues once again.
- Thank you for that response.
Unfortunately, we've only
got about two minutes left,
so I might try to squeeze
in one last question
if you're interested,
and it relates more to your own research,
which involves recovering
DNA from centuries ago.
And someone is asking what
those ancient DNA tell us
about ancient pathogens and pandemics.
- Yeah, that's very, very good questions.
Well, so I think one of
the important things that,
well, one of the first thing
I think is really important
is they can help really
identify the etiology
of a particular infectious epidemic.
And that might seem like,
well, that's sort of an easy answer,
but you have to understand
that in the absence,
in a vacuum of an identifiable agent,
blame can go in all sorts
of different directions.
So, remember, during the Black Death,
during that absence of
knowledge of what that was,
people of course blamed everybody
that you can imagine under the sun,
so prostitutes, Jews.
Everybody was either burned at the stake
or tortured in various ways
that we don't even want
to get into or talk about.
And that still, you would
think, "Oh, well, Hendrik,
"that's something of the past."
Well, no, think about HIV, right?
For the longest time,
the HIV wasn't even associated
as being a potential virus,
and because it happened to be
in a disenfranchised community,
in the homosexual community
in San Francisco and
New York and Montreal,
it was really stigmatized
as sort of unimportant and insignificant.
And when that identity became aware,
it was really significant.
So, I think one of the things
is really that immediate identity
of what those infectious
agents were in the past.
The second thing, of
course, is do we understand
if its behavior in the past is different
to how it might act still today
or if re-emergences continue to happen.
How can we actually modulate our behavior
differently depending upon that?
Are there things that we
can do to actually contact
and trace and be aware,
screen, for example,
if we know the evolutionary
history of that?
The third thing, of course,
is it talks about an
evolutionary descendant ratio
between the ancient infectious agents
and the contemporary ones,
and I think that plays
also an important role
in understanding its
evolutionary trajectory.
Where is it going from here?
Where has it been?
I think we're running out of time,
so I could go on and on about this topic.
- I'm sure you could.
That's been really,
really fantastic, Hendrik.
Thank you so much.
And I'd also really like to
thank everyone for joining in
and giving use such terrific
questions to feed you.
So, for everyone, please
visit our website, cifar.ca,
to find out more about this series.
We'll have a few more talks coming up,
and we also have previous
recorded talks available there.
But yes, just in signing off,
I'd like to thank you again, Hendrik,
and wish you all a great afternoon.
- [Hendrik] Well, thank you.
- Bye.